[Musique]
oui bienvenue parloto ici c'est Mélissa
de la côte nord justement dans la région
de sétile j'ai eu la chance dans la
dernière semaine de me promener un peu
partout sur le territoire et dans
inspiré justement pour ma chronique
cette semaine parce que autant dans mes
médias sociaux que dans les nouvelles
tout ce qu'on parle c'est non seulement
les élections mais aussi l'arrivée très
imminente du 30 septembre et de
l'anniversaire justement de Joyce et
chacuan de ce qui s'est passé alors on
revient à des sujets et je pense que
personne ne peut rater
je dirais la bourde que monsieur Legault
a dit en disant que si le problème
n'était pas réglé et bien c'était la
faute des étiquet mecs donc vous pouvez
imaginer comment il a dû se rétracter il
a dû s'excuser auprès des familles du
s'excuser auprès de la nation à tika mec
parce que
que ce n'est pas très représentatif de
la réalité mais c'est représentatif
d'une réconciliation qui a encore
beaucoup de travail à faire pour pouvoir
arriver et ça c'est normal on peut pas
régler tous les problèmes et dire kumbai
je suis certaine que comme Monsieur le
Gaulle a dit pour lui s'arrêter que une
seule formation envers des infirmières
il y en a plus de racisme systémiques
mais c'est un enjeu et c'est une
problématique présentement et quand je
parle d'un jeu de représentation je
pense aussi du fait que en plein milieu
des élections provinciales je me
retrouve à visiter le comté où est-ce
que deux représentants de la nation et
nous sont présentement en train de vivre
leur moment électoral une justement pour
le parti
de la CAQ et l'autre qui va être avec
Québec Solidar et c'est quand même assez
intéressant surtout quand on a l'oreille
au sol d'entendre ce qui se dit de voir
ce qui se fait du traitement justement
des pancartes électorales j'ai vu des
choses que j'étais quand même assez
étonné
vu le respect justement que les zinous
ont peu importe le parti que tu vas
choisir pour représenter bien il y a un
respect de la parole qui est portée par
quelqu'un alors je sais pas si je peux
attribuer certaines des activités
justement de décrochage de pancarte
d'altérance de pancarte à des membres de
la communauté et nous parce que je serai
m'étonnerait vraiment beaucoup mais rien
n'est impossible puisque nous rentrons
dans une nouvelle ère où nous
participons à des forums des élections
qui n'ont pas été bâties dans notre
aperçu culturel mais je pense aussi
qu'on rentre dans des politiques
québécoises et que peut-être justement
dans ce cadre-là il y a des choses qui
sont faites c'est sûr que ça aussi ça
fait partie de la discussion de voir des
pancartes par exemple de waptron qui
sont décrochés des pancarte aussi de
qui sont peut-être des fois tournés mais
des altérances aussi qui sont un peu
plus violents et qui demande à ce
questionner si notre place en tant
qu'inou peu importe le parti qu'on
choisit est vraiment sécuritaire dans
une politique qui elle peut être
agressive envers les peuples autochtones
dont le premier ministre qui fait
souvent des allusions un peu proches de
du gaz lighting de l'éclairage au gaz
qui
que les personnes qui sont victimes de
violence se sont encore plus
responsables de pourquoi ça leur arrive
donc vous comprendrez que c'est très
important de d'écouter de voir comment
cette course électorale est à deux
vitesses comment il y a deux aperçus un
pour l'autre
et que c'est en plein dans une semaine
qui précède un moment de réconciliation
un moment où ce que le racisme
systémique est mis au devant dans les
médias et en plus quelques jours
seulement avant les élections
provinciales donc il faut garder l'oeil
il faut voir que c'est un double poids
pour les personnes qui sont présentes
dans ces élections là
c'est assez intéressant mais c'est aussi
des fois assez troublant à voir ce qu'on
a encore beaucoup de travail devant nous
donc je vous souhaite une belle semaine
et j'espère justement que vous allez
nous envoyer des questions vous allez
vous tenir au courant de ce qui se passe
présentement dans les élections
provinciales autant pour les candidats
autochtones que pour les candidats à
l'automne et ce qu'ils ont apporté
justement pour la réconciliation alors
je vous souhaite une belle semaine